Ah. Grant.
I think I know what
you're here to say.
I've been spending
a lot of time with Beyoncé.
And this is not a review
of having a pet.
It's a review of putting
a pet to sleep.
That is what
I was going to say.
I feel like you're falling
for this lizard
and forgetting
what you have it for.
Uh, no. [Laughs]
Come on, Grant.
I'm not capable of falling
for anything except "Review."
Now, having said that,
I will not be
euthanizing Beyoncé.
Forrest.
No.
This is no regular
dime store lizard, Grant.
He just returned
from the brink of death.
Does that sound familiar?
That happened to you
and me too, right?
You relate to him, don't you?
I've gotten to know him.
And he's actually
extremely intelligent.
I mean, it's like,
there's a lot going on up there.
So it would be a crime.
Which is why I
have purchased --
aha! --
another pet for the express
purpose of keeping
for a couple of days
and then killing.
I'm gonna kill that one instead.
I named him Deyoncé.
Take a look.
Here you go.
Beyoncé and Deyoncé.
Friends for
1 or 2 days tops.
And then, that one,
I'm gonna kill.
That sounds fine.
Good.
Yeah.
Since any animal at all would do
for this assignment,
I felt I'd found a good way
to spare the life of a creature
with whom I had perhaps
developed some kind of
mutual respect.
But there was a terrible
flaw in my plan.
Forrest:
The picture is good,
but I wish it could
look more old-timey.
You know how old-timey
paper was all yellow, and --
Yes! Just like that!
Oh, that's perfect!
Okay.
[ Laughs ] Whoa.
Where's Beyoncé?
Josh: Isn't that Beyoncé?
No, this is my
new lizard, Deyoncé.
Whoa!
Where's Beyoncé?
Wait, did you 'em
in there together?
Yeah, why?
You shouldn't put two bearded
dragons in the same tank.
Why not?
Is that Beyoncé's foot?
Oh!
Okay.
Oh, no!
What happened?!
Yeah, sometimes they eat
each other. It's crazy.
What the [bleep]
are you talking about?!
I knew that.
There's videos on YouTube --
What the [bleep]
are you talking about?!
These [bleep] lizards
eat each other?!
Oh, so we both knew that.
Why the [bleep]
didn't you tell me that?!
Oh, I thought
we all knew that.
I put them both
in the same thing,
and one of them
ate the other one?!
[ Breathing heavily ]
Well, I deal
with grief alone.
[ Sobbing ]
Maybe he's in the cave?
Josh.
Yeah, okay.
All right.
I looked in
the [bleep] cave!
Forrest: I had no emotional
attachment to Beyoncé
and was not sad for myself.
But the injustice of what
had happened troubled me.
[ Sobbing ] My only friend
in the world!
[ Sobbing ]
♪♪
I'm so sorry.
After a period of reflection,
I decided that I had
bonded enough with Deyoncé
to have a genuine experience
of putting him to sleep.
You're comin' with me,
you piece of shit.
My experience of putting Deyoncé
to sleep was, frankly,
more like pet
capital punishment.
It was justice.
Regrettable,
but completely necessary.